a troubling new report from the
department of homeland security
highlights the lingering human costs
of the trump administration's family
separation policy at the border
the report says more than 2100 kids may
still be without their parents
despite recent efforts to reunite them
vice president kamala harris is in
mexico today to address the root causes
of the immigration crisis after visiting
guatemala yesterday
at o'keefe is in guatemala city ed how
does the vice president plan to do that
well good morning anthony another big
day ahead for the vice president as she
announced plans for the federal
government
to target human traffickers are those
people to help guide migrants across the
u.s mexico border
and plans to promote legal immigration
from central america and mexico
the ultimate goal here is to help make
it possible for people in this region
to feel they no longer need to head
north illegally
vice president kamala harris arrived in
mexico last night
before arriving she said the focus is on
bolstering a partnership
with our next door neighbors harris is
continuing her first foreign trip since
taking office
a tour that included a stern warning to
would-be illegal migrants
do not come do not come
hoping to alleviate poverty and crime
that drives many to make the trek north
the biden administration has committed
more than 300 million dollars to the
region
i have asked you what would bring the
people of guatemala hope
as harris met with civic and business
leaders she announced that the
departments of homeland security and
justice
are launching a new task force targeting
transnational crimes like human
trafficking
and across central america the state
department will begin promoting
legal ways to immigrate to the u.s but
she's also using the trip to raise
concerns with corruption
across central america do you consider
the governments of el salvador guatemala
honduras mexico or any other in this
region
to be corrupt so on the issue of
corruption the conversation that i had
with president john mate today was very
frank
and very candid and i think this is a
quality that he and i appreciate in each
other
i pressed guatemalan president alejandro
yamate about critics who say
that when it comes to corruption he's
part of the problem
how many cases of corruption have i been
accused of i can give you the answer to
that
zero back in washington republicans like
senator lindsey graham
question if the renewed american
investment in mexico and central america
is worth it i think the money alone
won't fix that problem
people are going to keep coming by the
hundreds of thousands
until we change our laws
now that new government report we
mentioned about 2100 kids that may not
yet have been reunited with their
families
acknowledges that in some cases there
may have been reunifications
but the government has no record of them
the department of homeland security also
says that it will help reunite another
29 families
in the coming weeks all of this a
reminder of the long simmering
deep-rooted problems of immigration
across this region
tony reminder indeed edoki forest in
guatemala ed thank you very much